voici l'un des grands chorégraphes de
notre époque
maurice béjart c'était hier à avignon
quelques heures avant la première de son
dernier spectacle la messe pour le temps
présent
une création mondiale que les
spectateurs du festival d'avignon ont
été les premières à maurice béjart vous
créer cette messe pour le temps présent
à avignon mais vous auriez pu le faire
parfaitement ailleurs pourquoi avoir
choisi avignon choisi avignon à cause du
lieu scénique et surtout à cause du
public à cause de ce lieu de rencontre
exceptionnelle à travers le monde qu'est
avignon et je ne pense pas que j'aurais
pu la créer ailleurs aussi bien
d'ailleurs j'ai tellement pensé en
fonction de d'avignon que le reprendre à
la rentrée à paris à bruxelles ou
ailleurs ne posera de grands problèmes
est-ce que cela rejoint un petit peu le
spectacle peter whittall pour longtemps
parce qu'il ya des comédiens qui
participent au spectacle parce qu'il ya
de l'action corporelle de la danse des
musiques très variées des percussions
mais c'est quand même un certain que
très concentré exactement comme une
cérémonie liturgique moïse les joueurs
quelle signification vouliez vous donner
ce titre messe pour le temps présent
il ya une double signification le môme s
impliquent cérémonie religieuse implique
croyances et le mot temps présent
implique actualité implique reflet de
notre vie quotidienne
donc deux choses qui ont l'air tout à
fait différente
j'essaye de les réunir dans le même
titre d'un même spectacle oui alors sur
le plan chorégraphique comment peut-on
définir le spectacle suspects c'est très
difficile puisque c'est un truc qui est
composite le temps présent c'est
sébastien complique tout une petite
image du temps présent je montre sur le
plan chorégraphique sera du classique le
plus pur ce qu'au début les danseurs
font de l'exercice à la barre jusqu'aux
danses les plus contemporaines comme le
jerk
ce